We know that the snake is
utilized conceptually and metaphorically as representation of transformation,
right,
because the snake is something that can shed its skin and be reborn.
We know that a snake is something that's innately attractive and terrifying
human beings and other primates so that if you come across a snake,
you're likely to be at least startled,
if not horrified by it,
but also attracted to it in a way that is underneath your voluntary
consciousness,
right?
Because snakes attract orienting reflex isn't they activate the systems
underneath your consciousness that actually govern the structure of that
consciousness.
We know that the snake can be well represented as well as internal chaos,
so imagine this,
imagine that it's not unreasonable for a self conscious mind searching for a
mode of self representation to remark on the parallels between the structure of
the snake and the spine and the brain.
Given that a snake is essentially a spine with a brain and then imagine as well
that the most archaic aspects of our nervous system,
those that govern novelty and orienting and anxiety responses are in fact
precisely those that were described by Mclean as nested inside the reptilian
brain and then imagine along with the Hindu Yogis,
that the purpose of Kundalini Yoga is to activate the circuitry that's
associated with that snake,
so to speak,
to produce a permanent state of alert wakefulness.
It's associated with consciousness,
so imagine this.
Imagine an animal like like a zebra grazing mindlessly in the herd with no
consciousness whatsoever,
and then imagine it's relatively undeveloped cortical structures activated
suddenly by the movement of a lion off in the perimeter and then imagine for
that brief moment the thought Zebra is actually conscious state.
That requires a tremendous amount of energy and difficult to maintain,
but because the threat and the uncertainty manifest itself within the zebras
mode of consciousness,
it wakes momentarily.
And then imagine that human beings are like that.
Zebra always because we've become self conscious because we know that the
unknown is around us all the time.
Even when we think we're safe,
we're never safe.
Imagine that the reason we're so conscious is because as a consequence of our
discovery,
of the possibility of our own mortality,
all this underlying circuitry that in other animals is only apparent when
they're startled or afraid or interested or curious.
In human beings.
It's on all the time and that's what makes us conscious and the reason for that
is because we developed enough cortical elaboration to note that we're always
threatened by everything that's around us.
And then imagine that.
Well,
that's pretty awful,
isn't it?
Because it's at the basis of all our innate existential,
but then imagine as well that without that terror pushing us forward and and our
constant reference to the dangerous aspect of the unknown,
we would have never been motivated to produce the kind of societies that we've
produced,
which are essentially very remarkably elaborated devices that enable us to find
some protection from that unknown and to manipulate,
manipulate it effectively,
and then remembering that Surrey,
we will return to genesis young says the snake was regarded by early gnostic
Christians as a kind of deity whose faculties were more developed and advanced
than the original daddy that actually structured the world.
The idea there being that the world initially was a pretty dismal place.
Everyone wasn't conscious.
We all existed at the level of the animal and then the snake came along and
said,
wake up.
Wake up.
And the movement from that state of unsolved consciousness paradise to this
profane state of awakening can be regarded not so much as a descent but as an
asset of sorts,
even though a painful one.
And then you have Gareth.
This commentary from Mephistopheles,
his representation of Satan and his capacity for temptation,
who says,
follow the adage of my cousin,
snake from dreams of godlike knowledge,
you will wake to fear in which your very soul shall quake a statement,
associating the human tendency to attribute to all revolutionary sources of new
information,
a kind of demonic being,
and then you have the problem of the woman.
Now we know that within the context of the Judeo Christian tradition,
women have unduly suffered for their role in tempting humanity in the embodied
form of Adam towards higher order self consciousness,
and then you think,
well,
let's just take a look at how human beings and their mating relationships differ
from those of other animals like chimpanzees to whom we are very closely
genetically related.
And if you look at the mating strategies of female chimpanzees,
you see that they really don't care who they sleep with,
so to speak.
Any old chimpanzee will do.
Now,
the last dominant male chimps tend to be chased away by the more dominant nailed
chimps,
but if a female than less dominant chimp can get the hell away from the watchful
gaze of the dominance hierarchy,
they're perfectly happy to mate.
Human females are not like that.
There is selective of maters and there's a tremendous body of evolutionary
psychological information that suggests that although both genders,
value intelligence and physical appearance,
females value the ability to attain dominance,
hierarchy status in men far more than men,
admire the ability to attain dominant status in women,
which is to say that men don't care what a woman has with regards to potential
for attaining status.
Whereas with women,
it's one of the strong determinant of mating preference.
So then let's say,
look,
we don't know why the hell are cortex has expanded so rapidly,
somewhere between five and 3 million years ago.
Let's offer this as a hypothesis.
The women started to get choosy and because they were so damn complicated,
the whole human species had to exaggerate it's critical growth prior to any even
use for that critical growth,
just so that the men had uneven hand in the competition,
right?
So women put tremendous selection pressure on the human being to develop
tremendous,
tremendous cortical expansion.
Now we already know that from a mythological perspective that women are
frequently cast into the same conceptual domain,
the temptress domain as the benevolent aspect of the unknown,
and we know as well from representations of hero mythology that it is the
individual who goes out to confront chaos,
who's most likely to free from the dragon,
not only treasured,
but a virgin,
say in the case of mythological representations like St George and the dragon
in the Old Testament in genesis,
there's no.
There's this notion that not only did people become self conscious because they
did something,
but they did this voluntarily,
right?
They,
they,
they made this decision on their own.
So Milton puts words into God's mouth and says,
so will fall.
He meaning the human being and his faithless progeny,
whose fault?
Whose about his own engrave he had of me,
oh,
he could have.
I made him Justin,
right?
It's efficient to have stood though free to fall,
and then you think,
well,
maybe the notion of the heritable sin of Adam characterizing human beings and
their fallen existential condition isn't just the black heart ravings of
fundamentalist southern Baptist lunatics,
right?
There's something to this.
Human beings are the only creatures that seem to live at odds with their own
experience and it's not so unreasonable to suppose that it's hard dawning
capacity for self consciousness that put us in that uncomfortable position.
So why do I associate the eating of the apple with selfconsciousness?
Well,
let's.
Because that's how the story lays itself out.
You have the collateral evidence of the Buddhist story of enlightenment,
right?
His contact with death.
You have multiple media,
medieval representations of Eve offering to animal to Adam.
Not An apple,
but a skull.
You have multiple representations of the tree,
of the knowledge of good and evil in medieval iconography as not containing
apples,
but containing skulls and you have the the statements that are within the
context of genesis itself.
And the eyes of both of them were opened and they knew that they were naked and
they sewed fig leaves together and made themselves aprons.
Well,
there's a lot of information packed into those two lines,
right?
What does it mean to have your eyes open?
Or half?
Your brain is visual cortex.
It's not on.
It's not unreasonable to presume that that means a quick,
a quick magnification of consciousness.
Your conscious during the day,
that's when your eyes are open or what happens when your eyes are open?
Oh,
you know you're naked.
Well,
what does that mean?
you know,
you're vulnerable,
right?
To social comment,
to social judgment,
to dominance,
hierarchy,
status maneuvering,
and to all the terrible things that the unknown world can,
can recap on you.
And so then what do you do?
Oh,
you create culture,
right?
And that's what this little sentence says.
And they sewed fig leaves together and made themselves aprons.
That's a pretty eventful sequence all crammed up in two little sentences.
So then what happens?
I think it's extremely interesting.
So before Adam and eve figure out that they're naked,
they're cruising around the garden.
Having a fine time doing whatever they want.
They don't take any thoughts for the future,
right?
I don't have a prefrontal cortex.
They're living in a in a paradox lists environment like an animal lives.
Well,
what happens after they become self conscious?
prior to this,
Adam's walking around with God,
right,
and you think about what that means.
It means something like this.
An animal isn't in the world of good and evil and animal nature points out is
beyond good and evil,
right?
Enraptured in entirely by the actions of automatic instinct governed by
processes that are completely transcendent.
The animals,
nothing but a force of nature.
There is no opposition between the animal in the world.
The animal is the world,
and just as in the case of the animal,
prior to the eating of the apple,
Adam walks around the garden with God.
There's no discontinuity between him and the and the transcendent world as such,
but as soon as he becomes naked,
he hides well.
Why?
Well,
that doesn't need to be answered.
All you have to think about it.
Why would you hide if you know you're naked?
Well,
it's simple.
You'll hide because you think you can get hurt.
You think that whatever you are is so vulnerable that if it shows itself to the
transcendent to others,
to the natural world,
that something terrible will happen,
and then you think,
well,
that's a pretty logical presupposition,
right?
Look at us.
So God comes cruising around the garden after Adam and Eve,
the apple in the cool of the day and Adam and Eve hide themselves among the
trees of the garden and God says to Adam,
Hey,
where are you?
Adam says,
I heard your voice,
and I was afraid because I was naked and I hid myself,
and that story has bottomless depth because it means something like this.
At the beginning of genesis,
there's this notion that there is a transcendent relationship between the
individual and God,
right?
The identity of logo 70 individual,
I know it shouldn't by the way,
that our entire idea of intrinsic human right,
it's predicated on it as we've been at some pains to demonstrate a relationship
between the limited and the limitless eradicated by the dawn of self
consciousness.
What does that mean?
Well,
let's say you have a destiny just for the sake of argument,
right?
Because you are a being with a tremendous history and an unbelievable potential.
So let's say you have a destiny just for the sake of argument,
what would cause you to hide from that destiny?
Well,
obviously
your own reflections on your mortal vulnerability,
right?
How could I be characterized by any transcendent power whatsoever when I'm
susceptible to social alienation,
right?
When I have this body which is capable of terrifying degeneration that will
eventually decay into old edge and that is bounded by death.
How could I be good for anything which is precisely what this little story says,
and so God figures out that Adam and eve ate the fruit and that's pretty
decisive move because once you wake up,
sorry,
you're awake,
and he says,
and this is not an injunction,
by the way,
this is a description,
all right,
you've done it now unto the woman.
He says,
I will greatly multiply the Isaura night conception in sorrow shalt thou bring
forth children.
Why?
Well,
we have a big CORTEX,
right?
Really big.
It grew fast and what that meant is that there was an evolutionary arms race
between skull size,
date of birth,
and pelvic diameter girth.
The wider the pelvis,
the less effectively you can walk a larger the skull.
The bigger the brain,
the younger the baby,
the more dependent and vulnerable.
So what do we have in the case of human beings,
the female human pelvis has already stretched to the limits of its structural
capacity.
So the hole in its center is as big as it can get without compromising the
structural integrity of the pelvis while still allowing women to walk and run.
So how have babies adapted to that?
Oh,
that's simple.
A mammo of our size should have a gestation period of two years.
We have a gestation period of nine months.
Why you got to get the damn baby out before it's head gets too big?
What does that mean?
Well,
it means it's vulnerable,
right?
Nothing more vulnerable than a baby human being except maybe a baby kitten room.
Right?
But it's got a pouch to hide in at least.
So we're born vulnerable,
right?
Characteristic of the birth of the hero.
Who suffers in childbirth?
Women.
Why?
Baby skulls?
Just a little bit too big,
has to be crunched and compacted during birth,
right?
The skull bones aren't joined together so that the baby's head can be squashed
and visibly deformed during the process of birth.
Prior to the 20th century,
what was the death rate among women giving birth?
One in three,
one in five.
Terrible.
Why?
That's the price you pay for self consciousness
and I desire shall be to the husband and he shall rule over thee.
This is not an injunction.
This is a description.
The additional burden that dependent offspring place on women,
place them at a disadvantage.
What's the consequence of that from a historical perspective?
Well,
any feminist can answer that question,
right?
Add on to Adam.
He said,
because you listened to your wife and have eaten the tree of which I commanded
thee,
saying,
don't eat that.
Cursed is the ground for the sake in sorrow shall though he'd have it for all
the days of thy life.
Fair enough,
right?
Once you're self conscious,
you work.
Why?
Well,
animals don't work.
Why do people work well?
Because we know,
right,
we know that if it isn't gonna happen today,
it's going to happen tomorrow and if it isn't going to happen tomorrow,
what's going to happen next week or the week after the month after the year
after and we bloody well better prepare.
So that's what we do.
Constantly prepare and prepare and prepare so we're not bounded and motivated by
what's happening from second to second like the animal is in.
It's still paradisical state.
We're constantly tormented by an endless string of what if questions,
because when we look at the unknown,
we can see the possibility for everything including our own punishment or own
tournament,
our own demise,
and so we're motivated like no other animal to work and so we work.
But that is another aspect that alienates us from paradise.
Wellbeing
thorns and thistles shall it bring forth for the analysis.
You'll eat the herb of the field in the sweat of thy face shalt thou eat bread
til thou return unto the ground for Dust Thou art and unto dust shall thou
return,
right?
Therefore,
the Lord God sent him forth from the garden of Eden to till the ground from
whence he was taken.
So he drove out the man and he placed at the east of the garden of Eden
Cherubims and a flaming sword which turned every way to keep the way of the tree
of life.